die ufo videos aus den usa zeigen
tatsächlich echte flugobjekte das sagt
das us verteidigungsministerium jetzt
doch eine erklärung gibt es für die
mysteriösen objekte am himmel immer noch
nicht denn ihre flugbewegungen sind
nicht nur extrem schnell sondern sie
verschwinden auch urplötzlich von der
einen auf die andere sekunde die us
geheimdienste stehen unter druck um was
geht es hier wirklich um und
identifizierte phänomene ufos oder
unbekannte flugzeuge möglicherweise neue
militärtechnologie klicks umsatz im
future bis dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivität locken nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen mit spannung wird
ende des monats der kurzbericht der
us-geheimdienste erwartet gefühlt wartet
die ganze welt darauf das thema die
videos mit den unbekannten flugobjekten
die teilweise bereits vor vielen jahren
gemacht wurden und vor vier jahren 2017
veröffentlicht wurden nun soll endlich
die große frage geklärt werden um was es
sich wirklich handelt um bekannte
flugzeuge ja möglicherweise sogar um
neue militärtechnologie oder eben um und
identifizierte phänomene ufos
außerirdisches leben dass wir nun
endlich entdeckt haben das ganze netz
ist im alien fieber nachdem sich sogar
der ehemalige us präsident barack obama
zum thema geäußert hatte werden die
aufnahmen nicht nur auf twitter und
facebook sondern an so offen dass
natürlich auch auf youtube sondern auch
in vielen podcast heißt diskutiert kein
wunder denn obama selbst hatte die ganze
alien diskussion noch angeheizt
es gibt viele videoaufnahmen von
objekten am himmel von dem wir nicht
genau wissen was sie sind wir können
ihre bewegungen und flugbahn nicht genau
erklären
die videos über die wir hier erst vor
kurzem war klicks und wirtschaft
berichtet hatten sind jedenfalls
authentisch so eine neue bewertung des
us-verteidigungsministeriums echte
piloten an bord von f a 18 kampfjets
haben demnach die aufnahmen also
mitgeschnitten dazu hatte lewis elizondo
vom pentagon vorprogramm in einem us tv
sender gesagt dass einige dieser objekte
zitat alles übertreffen was wir in
unserem inventar haben und weiter zitat
wir wissen was auch immer das in
im himmel ist es ist echt die frage ist
was ist es schon vor einigen wochen war
die debatte entbrannt der neue begriff
des us militärs ab und das steht für
unidentifizierte phänomene im luftraum
und klar ist auch diese mysteriöse
phänomene die sich nach aussagen
verschiedener us kampfpiloten
detektieren ließen können möglicherweise
zitat die nationale sicherheit bedrohen
teilweise wurden die mysteriösen objekte
über militärisch gesperrtem luftraum
gesicht ja sogar überstunden und das
viele tage hintereinander
konkret geht es unter anderem um ein
video das im jahr 2004 aufgenommen
worden war zwei us kampfpiloten hatten
wirklich erstaunliches zu berichten
demnach hatten sie ein mysteriöses
objekt etwa 15 meter oberhalb der
wasseroberfläche draußen im pazifik
aufgespürt das sei nicht nur rund 13
meter lang sondern habe sich auch in
einer unvorstellbaren geschwindigkeit
fortbewegt allerdings erst als die
piloten sich immer weiter näherten dazu
einer der piloten in einem interview mit
der times es beschleunigte wie nichts
was ich jemals gesehen habe
die piloten seien dann weiter zu ihrem
treffpunkt geflogen etwa hundert
kilometer entfernt dort entdeckten sie
das objekt dann wieder
demnach muss ist die strecke in sehr
kurzer zeit zurückgelegt haben und genau
diese merkmale werden in allen videos
offenbart die beobachteten objekte
beschleunigen extrem schnell und
verschwinden plötzlich von der einen auf
die andere sekunde
die augenzeugen des us-militärs
berichten von einer hyper
schallgeschwindigkeit in bis zu 10.000
metern höhe und das ohne sichtbaren
antrieb auch abgaswolken hatten die
mysteriösen objekte demnach nicht hinter
sich hergezogen und genau das lässt nach
ansicht der piloten nur eine
schlussfolgerung zu menschen können
nicht dahinter stecken denn dafür sei
die beschleunigung viel zu unvermittelt
passiert und das in einem raschen
wechsel mit abrupten stopp dazu sagte
der pilot ryan grey's in einem interview
mit der new york times geschwindigkeit
bringt dich um anhalten bringt dich um
oder beschleunigung im jahr 2017 wurden
die aufnahmen erstmals veröffentlicht
und seitdem beschäftigt sich das
us-verteidigungsministerium intensiv
damit vor knapp einem jahr wurde dann
die sogenannte uab task force gegründet
die sich ausgiebig mit den ereignissen
beschäftigen soll ein erster kurzbericht
sei am 25 juni 2000
21 veröffentlicht werden das hatte der
ehemalige us präsident donald trump noch
so verfügt das heißt also im klartext
dass sowohl die geheimdienste als auch
das pentagon vor dem kongress offenlegen
müssen was sie über die uab geschehen
ist wissen
der frühere geheimdienst direktor john
radcliffe hat sich jedenfalls im märz
diesen jahres gesagt es gibt vielmehr
sichtungen als öffentlich gemacht werden
der kongress erwartet neben dem
kurzbericht in diesem monat auch noch
eine längere fassung mit klassifizierten
also geheimen informationen zur sachlage
bereits im vergangenen jahr hatte das
pentagon drei videos mit als zitat nicht
identifiziert eingestuften flugobjekten
veröffentlicht für andere beobachtung
dagegen gibt es schon mögliche
erklärungsversuche dazu sagt der
ehemalige stellvertretende
verteidigungsminister für geheimdienste
küste formellen die anderen aufnahmen
zeigen langsamere flugobjekte in
niedrigerer höhe
diese könnten einen staatlichen akteur
wie china oder russland zugeschrieben
werden ein pentagon vertreter betonte
aber auch noch mal dass solche
mysteriösen sichtung auch ganz andere
erklärungen haben könnten auch drohnen
oder wetterballons könnten dahinter
stecken heißt also für viele seltsame
erscheinung oder lichter am himmel gibt
es einige erklärungsmöglichkeiten wie
unter anderem auch das wetter meteo
schauer oder beispielsweise flugzeug
test es gibt zudem auf viele fachleute
die ufo-sichtungen auch mit technischen
fehlern oder neurologischen
überlastungen der piloten erklären so
auch der astrophysiker wie in galopp der
vor einiger zeit in einem interview mit
der new york times technische fehler im
code für die bildschirme als erklärung
in betracht gezogen hatte die liste ist
also lang wenn es videos oder fotos von
unbekannten objekten gibt könnten diese
oft durch vögel oder insekten erklärt
werden die in einem speziellen winkel
heranfliegen aber auch linsen
reflektionen im objektiv sind auch
verantwortlich für das was man dort
angeblich sieht ein objekt das sich
eigentlich eher langsam bewegt kann dann
sehr schnell erscheinen bisher hatte
sich das pentagon eher verschlossen
gezeigt und so steigt die spannung wenn
der kurzbericht dann ende juni
vorgestellt wird doch klar ist auch dass
es den fachleuten des
verteidigungsministeriums hier nicht
wirklich darum geht grüne männchen von
anderen welten aufzuspüren viel
wichtiger ist den g die frage ob es sich
möglicherweise um neue rüstungstechnik
von anderen staaten handeln und genau
das wäre für die usa natürlich das
worst-case-szenario dazu die pentagon
sprecherin zugang mit dem sammeln
zusätzlicher daten wollen wir die kluft
zwischen identifiziert und nicht
identifiziert schließen und strategische
überraschung blick auf gegnerische
technologie vermeiden
doch da es dem pentagon er um diese
frage geht als um das ausspülen
außerirdischen lebens gibt es bislang
auch eher wenige informationen zur
thematik das us militär will dann
natürlich nicht offen legen wieder genau
der kenntnisstand ist denn dann hätten
andere länder ja die möglichkeit
rückschlüsse darauf zu ziehen
inwieweit die usa solche objekte orten
und zu ordnen können offiziell können
die vereinigten staaten des offenbar
bislang nicht benennen was ich da
offenbar wiederholt in ihrem luftraum ab
spielt dazu sagt christopher melden
der ehemalige stellvertretende
verteidigungsminister für geheimdienste
wir glauben unser luftraum sei sicher
tatsächlich haben fluggeräte straffreien
militärische sperrzone überflogen und
das regelmäßig über mehrere jahre
umfragen in den usa zeigen dass viele
amerikanerinnen amerikaner an
außerirdische und ufos glauben eine
befragung von zwei jahren 2009/10 hatte
ergeben dass ein drittel der befragten
davon ausgehen dass es sich bei einigen
der gesichteten ups tatsächlich um
außerirdische handelt 75 prozent der
befragten sind sich sicher das zitat
leben in irgendeiner form irgendwo im
universum existiert und davon sind auch
viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler mittlerweile überzeugt
dazu der astronom cez schostag vom seti
institute einer
nichtregierungsorganisation die sich ja
mit außerirdischem leben intensiv
beschäftigt es gibt zwei billionen
anderer galaxien die wir sehen jede mit
100 milliarden erdähnlichen welten es
ist schwer zu glauben dass diese welten
alle steril sind ende juni also wird der
kurzbericht erwartet die große frage
lautet allerdings bereits jetzt wissen
wir dann mehr oder wird es dann durch
die veröffentlichung der ersten
informationen noch mehr fragen geben
versteht bereits jetzt auch an anderen
ländern dieser welt geht die ufo debatte
nicht vorbei auch das
verteidigungsministerium des vereinigten
königreichs großbritannien denkt darüber
nach das offizielle info büro zu
reaktivieren allerdings nur falls der
bericht aus den usa neue erkenntnisse zu
den unidentifizierten flugobjekten gibt
so berichtet es die britische tages
zeitung the daily telegraph unter
berufung auf anonyme quellen jeden tag
ufos über dem atlantik außerirdisches
leben auf der spur
in diesem video gibt es noch mehr infos
über die ufo sichtung also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren das geht auch
ganz einfach auf den abo button hier
unter diesem video klicken überhaupt
unter jedem video das ist sogar komplett
kostenlos also tausend dank dafür und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran